bu ve çok güzel bir telif etkinliğinde
beraberiz burada özellikle Korkmaz Yiğit
Anadolu Lisesi'nin bu değerli öğrencinin
Çok teşekkür ediyorum Çok güzel
operasyon yaptılar bugün konumuz
tuslayarak ben biraz tekrar yerden
bahsetmek istiyorum kendi kalemize işine
katacağım bazı örnekler vereceğim Umarım
faydalı olurum karıya ne demek Öncelikle
kariyer sanatçıdan esası dilimize geçen
bir kedim yüzden yol mesaj falan da
geliyor Dolayısıyla burada şey çok
önemli bir yol var bu yol uzundu yok ve
bu yok izlenen bir yol Dolayısıyla Biz
an yola girmeliyiz hangi yoldan devam
etmeliyiz ve bol yanlış çıkarsa ne
yapmalıyız Bugün bunları görmek
istiyorum kendimden biraz bahsetmek
istiyorum Öncelikle 23 yıldan beri işe
atın içindeyim Galatasaray Lisesi'nde
Galatasaray simitsiz İşletmeyi iki tane
16 yaşında tutmaya çalıştım Tamam peki
melekler ardından mavide çalıştım daha
sonra da therapies nasıl yolunu yaptım
Dolayısıyla kariyerimde pazarlama var
satış var dijital var yatırım fonu var
yerleşik et var mı atmışlar şirket
bakalım Dolayısıyla şey görme şansım
oldu Ne tarafta nasıl oluyor İşler nasıl
dönüyor gibi 1985 yılda geri dönmek
istiyorum 1985 yılında ne oldu din985
yılında ilk defa katma değer vergisi
hayatımıza girdi ikinci Boğaz
Köprüsü'nün temellerinin atıldığı
bankaların reklam yapma yasağı getirildi
televizyonda düşünmemiş bankalar kendi
reklamını yapıyorlardı 12 nüfus sayımı
yapıldı ve Türkiye nüfusu 50 milyondu
esas bunlara baktınız abi gelmiyor 1985
yılında Ben [ __ ] açısı kazandım Hayır
mı 4 baktığınız zaman ne beni esaslı en
çok
mı diye Galatasaray sizi girmeye
sayabilirim Şimdi ben Çorlu'da duydum
Çorlu Tekirdağ bir ilçesinde o
zamanlarda bir kadar büyük değil böyle
30 bin nüfuslu bir köyden biraz daha
girişi bir yerde Babamın işi Dolayısıyla
Çorlu'da okumak zorundayım kardeşimle
Beraber tabi imkanlar İstanbul ve
Ankara'nın imkanları gibi daha küçük bir
yerdesiniz iki tane İlkokulu var o
dönemde böyle oralardan İstanbul
kazanmak çok da rahat değil 1983-84
yılında böyle İstanbul'a geliyoruz
alimleri Haber hafta sonları gezmeye
Baba Annemlerde kalıyoruz beyoğlu'ndan
geçerken bir kapı gördüm çok büyük
devasa bir kapı demir kapı ilk baba
Burası neresi ülke Burası Galatasaray
size o zaman Galatasaray'da orta okuldan
alıyordu ilkokuldan Sonra girebiliyoruz
sınavla benim burası güzel bir İlkokulu
benziyor ha lokasyon iyi dev gibi nasıl
Ulan ben burayı kazanmak istiyorum Babam
biraz da böyle mi beni de çok ileride
etkiler
bu kadarıyla yattım çok güzel hesabından
anlamadı beni Galatasaray kazanmak da
çok kolay değil esaslı eder Dolayısıyla
İnşallah kazanırsın elinden yeniden
kazanmasını üzülmedim Neden onu kafama o
okula girmeyi koydum ve bütün çalışmamı
esasında Çorlu gibi küçük şehirde bile
bunun üzerine yoğunlaştım ilkokul
öğretmenimiz birçok de emekli olmakla
beraber İstanbul'dan duyurdu arkadaşımız
özel ders kitabında Dershaneye
gidiyorlar dükkanlar yok o zamanlar
Bulgaristan'dan Türkiye'ye gelen
göçmenler vardı Çok akıllı çok çalıştım
insanları Bulgar Türkleri denir
dağıtanlara onlardan bir tanesini koca
olduğunu Bulgaristan'da çok iyi bir
oyuncu olduğunu duyduk Ee milattan video
caydı Biz milyoncudan özel ders almaya
başladım milli gündüzleri inşaatlarda
çalışıyor boyu yapıyor Akşamları ders
veriyordu bu şekilde ben 1985 yılında
çok braketten ve Sal
bu çalışmada beraber hayallerini
gerçekleştireceğim listeye girmiş oldum
Benim Bence kariyeri mesafe buradan
başlıyor genelde Kral üniversiteden
sonra başlıyor derler ne böyle değil
Bence insan hayatında sizi en çok
etkileyen gelişiminize katkı sağlayan
yer ortaokul lise çaldır burada ne
yaptın olduğu zorlanmaya başlıyorsunuz
Ne istediğinizi hesapta bunu biraz daha
iyi anlıyorsun en iyi dostluklar hesabı
ortaokul lise kuruyorsunuz diğerleri
biraz daha hepsi Dostlar olabiliyor
Dolayısıyla ben rahat açısıyla beraber
esasında benim kendi kalelerim başlamış
oldu Assassin's olsa Matematik Bölümü
seçmem satış pazarlama yakın olduğunu
düşündüğüm için ne Üniversitesi İşletme
önüne hedef alan bunlarla beraber
Ağabeyim ben Galatasaray Lisesi'ne
gidiyorum Galatasaray sitesinde bu
bitmez bu numara Hatta bildiren O da
güzel yanı işletmenin dereceli kazandım
iyi okul ikinci bir
Ben o zamanlar şu düşünüyordum dangal
servisi bitirdim Galatasaray Lisesi'ni
bitirdim her yerin kapıları bana çık
esasında Hala bir iş bulurum Evet öyle
olmuyor E çünkü bilmece çok zeki
binlerce kat en çok Değerli öğrencim
ağabey Herkes farklı biliyorsunuz ne
zaman şanslıydım paketten iş buldum bunu
şöyle miydi size tavsiyem olacak
esasında okulda zorunlu olmasına rağmen
beş tane farklı staj yaptım bir örnek
verilmesi okul iki sınıfına başlayan
istiyordum iyi bankaya gireceğimi
bankacı olacağım Okul bittiğinde alttan
Bankası olmakta vazgeçmiştim Finans
kesip de istemiyorum yapmış sayılarda
gördüklerinden dolayı ve kendimin
esasında daha çok pazarlama ve
sıkacaksın olduğunu gördüm ben onun
Türkiye'ye gelmişti o zaten olsaydı
Sabancı Holding ortaklığı vardı iş
başvurusunda bulundum ben onun pazarlama
departmanına beni satış teknoloji
görüştürdü
Selam söyle benden onda pazarlama-satış
şekilde kabul edildim hayalim şuydu çok
büyük bir şirket Tamam biliyorsunuz
Tamam dünyadan Türkiye'de en çok böyle
güzel ofise gideceğim Arkadaşlar böyle
bankalarda işe girdiler ve Danışmanlık
şirketini şekiller böyle Price
waterhouse coopers ve 6'nın 4'ü
şirketlerde çok değişti kıyafetler
ofiste Rüzgar ki Emre pazartesi işe
başlıyorsun mavi Alibeyköy'de ofisiniz
bu gibi navigasyonlarda yok Alibeyköy'de
hayatımda hiç görmedim bir kere sadece
İstanbul'daki su bastı diyorsun arrest
aşar meşhurdur Eskiden o zamanlar
görüyordum ve gittim adresten bulma
şekliyle buldum işe başladım çok hızlı
takip ettim 98 yolu işe başladım mm
yılında satış şefi oldum bu akşam girdim
2000'de satış yasağı oldum mm
o Müdür oldum mm dörtlü Grup Müdür oldum
Benim kira benim genelde olmasaydın çok
hızlı Ben helal edin bir 2007-2008 gibi
Genelde olurum Yani böyle hızlı
gidiyorum gayet güzel başörtü E hiç öyle
olmuyor Arkadaşlar bazı zamanlar çok
hızlı gidiyorsunuz bazı zamanlar
yaşlıyım diyorsunuz satış direktörü
olmam Grup Müdürü olduktan sonra
yaklaşık 8 9 sefer Çünkü o biraz oluşunu
boş olması da biraz şansınıza biraz o
günkü işlere bağlı olduğu için ve
hakikaten böyle artık umudunu kaybetme
Hoş geldin Neden sıkı şekli olamıyorum
arada Grup bir oldum diye dolu ise
kariyer Uzun Bir Yol yol içinde bazı
işler bazen çıkışlar olacak bunları çok
bakmak lazım Daha çok uzun vade
odaklanmak lazım ödedik kariyerde nelere
dikkat etmeliyiz gel ne yapmalıyız
zekalı yerimiz biraz daha şekillendirme
liyiz birkaç daha çok istiyorum bir
tanesi bu mutlaka stajı
Ben biliyorum kulüplerinde taşımak çok
kolay değil ama bu mesajları sana Sizi
nereye daha yatkın olduğunuzu Neyi daha
çok istediğiniz ve en iyi anlatan işler
olmuyor sevgili şıp okuldan mezun
olurken eminim içinde ne yaptın oldu ne
istediğini biliyorsunuz Annem onu istedi
babam bunu istediğini teyzemle oldu Çok
iyi ok attı Hanım Kız Doktor bunlara
takılmıyorum Siz ne istiyorsunuz Çünkü
çok uzun bir yola çıkıyorsunuz ve bu yol
esasında sizin kendi hayatınız
baktığınız zaman mutlaka yaptım işte
Hadi insanları dokunun İnsanları sakın
küçümsemeyin insanların gönlünde
kalbinde diğer bırakın Sanjar olurken de
bunu yapabilirsiniz genel Ülker da
yapabilirsiniz benim ve insanlar çok
önemli İnsandan Sonra Network sosyal
hayat Sosyalden geliyorsun çok önemli
olmakla beraber esas işe adlı bir sosyal
de çok kullanıyorsunuz bunu da annene
sor ki yapmanız değişik
bu bağlantınız oluyor olması ve her
zaman uzun vadede topları açacaktır
büyük iş hayatında Uzun Yolda Esasında
Çok güzel yalnız değilsiniz çok değerli
insanlarla çalışacaksınız bu iş yerinden
olabilir özel hayatınızda olabilir Ocağı
neden olabilir mutlaka kendisi iyi
mentorlar seçin bir şey danışmak
istediğiniz de örnek almak istediği
zaman bu insanlarla mutlaka kontağa
geçip size biraz diyalog Yani bir nevi
esası iş psikolog düşünebilirsiniz Ama
ben kimseyi birebir öyle kalmayın Mesela
ben hayatımı çok yapmışımdır kimseyle
böyle kalmam yöneticiler de yeni çıktım
özelliklerini çekmeye çalışırken
kötülerden çok faydalı Bu arada iyi
olmayan Şirinler karşılaşacaksınız
onların esasında hangi özelliklerini
almak istemiyorsunuz o tarafa bakma
bu fotoğrafa Yalnız çok önemli olacak en
sonunda esaslı Sizsiniz Dolayısıyla
kendiniz gibi olmalısınız size küçük bir
hikaye anlatayım Einstein birden çok
fazla konferans geliyormuş ve
konferanslar giderken de hep bir şoför
kullanıyormuş şoförlüğü en haklı
oturuyormuş ve Einstein anlattı
dinliyormuş sorular geldi ancak bana
bakıyormuş dedim giderken toplantıda bir
konferansa edilmişken Einstein demiş
Bugün senin anlatacağını çok iyi
biliyorum ne cevaplayacağım da çok iyi
biliyorum ne sonra geleceğin ediyorum
dolu işte bu esasa çok zor birşeydi
konferanslar vermektedir İşte bu gün
gideceğimiz iade beni çok tanımıyorlar
yani FIFA bilmiyorlar istersen yani yağ
değişim şapkasını Ece kedili şoförüne
vermiş ve şoför konferansta sahneye
çıkmış o yüzden arka geçmiş olur
hakkaten şoför döşendi konferans varmış
bütün gelen
çok güzel cevaplamış bırak bitmek
üzereyken bir tane bir fizikçi bayağı
Sağlam Zor bir fizik töreni sormuş demiş
ki Einstein i Bununla ilgili yorumu
nedir demiş şoför açabilecek durum yok
şoför demiş ki bu soruyu sorduğumda çok
şaşırdım en arka sırada oturan fırını
daha sorsam cevap var demiş ve sahne
şoför olarak Einstein etmiş aysanti de
çok güzel Şehir ölmüş burada şoför o
anda günü kurtarmış Ama gülüm
kurtaramayacağı nız belki kadar
olacaktır O yüzden siz kendiniz olmaya
kendi yaptığı en iyi yapmaya çaba sarf
edin yaptığınız işten keyif alın Yani
keyfiniz ödemeyin başarıyla başarı
başarısızsa başarısızlık ama o anın
tadını çıkartın söyle söyleyim ben
herhalde inşaatında Hedef almıştır
satışta çalışıyoruz abi aletlerimiz
vardı biliyorsun işte bu ay bu kadar
satış yapacağım o hedefin keyfine varmak
bu gündür ayakkabının Elif Tutar o
dersimize korkuyordum satış yaptım ok
bir başlar Bu sefer asla bitmeyecek
hayatınızda yok keyfinize ödemeyin Biz
kalın risk almadan takip plasis kalmadı
hayatınız iyi geri gelemez beni en büyük
önem budur Konfor alanından çıkın Ben
öyle insanlarla karşılaşıyorum ki çok
iyi iş yapıyor Ponpon the mystery
bozulmasın takip etmeyeyim Ondan sonra
bu yetiyor diyor Benim mesaj at k24
baktığınız zaman hiç aldın mı çok aldım
satışta çalışırken pazarlara geçtim
pazarda çalışırken econosto dişlere
geçtim orada bu yaparken kategoride
Patlamaya gitti mavide kadınlardan sonra
siyoluk yaptım list almasaydım bu kadar
çok şeyi 23 yıl gibi zamanda ölemezdim
yani Öyle insanlar var ki bir proje
satışa
Ben 23 yıl boyunca Muhasebede çalışıyor
size tavsiyem kendinizi çeşitlendi rin
Merhaba Antep bir şirkette çalışmaya çok
önemli yorum yani kötü demiyorum ama ben
kendime konuşuyorum birkaç şirket
göremez kariyerinizde farklı kültürlerde
tanışmanız anlamına geliyor çık Ben onda
da Fransızlar da çalışıp Fransız
kültürünü öğrenirken rahatsız ciddi
özellikle Fransa çok ismidir çıtırtı
Hatta amerikalılara çalıştım Amerikalı
daha rahat Ama mutlaka Sen hedefi
bekleyen sürekli Dolayısıyla Eğer Risk
almaktan kaçınmayın gerektiğinde yardım
istedim yardım istemek ayıp bir şey
değildir birçok arkadaşım mesaj yazdım
istemez yaşlı ben sonunda karşılığını
kendin Hayır kendin yazmışsın Yarın ayıp
bir şey değildir birey yine bir başka
şeyi konuştuk olursak esasında karar
verici olun mutlaka işte
Evet şu iletelim var ek-6 bileti
sorumluluktan kaçma yayından buradayım
diye bir şey olduğu zaman bir sorun
varsa ben buradayım ben çözmek için ben
gelir yaparım diye genelde böyle artık
daha çekilenler sorunu gördüğümde yandan
kaçmaya çalışanlar kariyerlerinde çok
uzun süre koşucu olamıyorlar esasında
uzun konuşmak istiyorsanız e-control
olmamız gerekiyor Size geliştiren
görüntülerle karşılaşacağımız kadar
esasında örnek almayacağız insanlara
çıkacaktır bunların bir kısmı
geliştirecek takip götürecektir aynısı
kendimden güzel Tamam anlatmak istiyorum
ki böyle kattayım bir Amerikalı genel
müdürümüz var Aaron Paul kuvvetli bir
adam ödevi bir adam şu anda hatta
asya-pasifik başkanı Yani 6 milyar
dolarlık bir ciro yönetiyorlar bir sürü
dinlersin vapurlar pazarlama geçirdi
beni o da biz kaldı Bendeniz kaldım ya
Bu kitap atmaya çalışmam uzun yıllardan
beri seni pazarlamanın bir bölümünün
başına geçiyorum dedi elbisenin London
Business school a o zamanın parasıyla
onbin parça olması lazım işte bugün
baktığımız zaman bayağı yüksek böyle
olmaz diyoruz bir eğitime yollayacağım
de şu Baran halk pazarını geçiyorum suda
gidiyorum şirketi parayı karşı Otel
bedava yemek bedava bu bela Harika bir
şey sansın olur ama yanlış şirketler
öyle zarar etmekte etmemek arasında
oyalı böyle kapatmaya çalışıyor şimdi
benim o para esas önemli bir hale geldi
yani o yüzbin liralar bugün para 200
lira böyle şey pozisyonda şekilde önemli
evine gittim Elim dedim Ben bir şey
istiyorum ben bunu gitmeyeyim bu iptal
edelim şirket bu kadar Ali bir yere
gitmeye çalışırken Ali ben bunu Açmak
istemiyorum O zaman elim çok güzel ders
verdi senin paranla 10000 Panda
şirketleri zengin olmaz
bu ordunun alacağım eğitim ve ilerki
yıllarda şirketi çok çok daha büyük
parçalar sahipleneceksin oyunda etme
gittim şirketine zarar etti ama önemli
değil Elif hakikaten yatırım yapmaya
Selam üretici İnşallah Gök kar yağardı
başarılı olmanın yollarından bir tanesi
adapte olmak hayat çok hızlı değişiyor
Teknoloji çok hızlı değişiyor adapte
olabilen ler hayatta kalıyor ve
hayatlarını idame diyorlar dairenin
meşhur sözünü hatırlarsınız ve Güçler
kazanacak diyor bezi plaka kazanca
adapte olabilen ler değişimi açılanlar
esas ayakta kalacaktır bu çok doğru
Hayat şu anda çok çok hızlı değişiyor
halinde bir çalışma karşınızda dolayı
silah değişme açıklamanız lazım vaktimiz
varken hayallerinizi gerçekleştirin
sakın öteleme yine 20 yıl sonra 25/110
esaslar
Sen konuş konular neler yaptığından
dolayı pişman değil nedir yapmadığım
için pişman diyeceksiniz bu çok önemli
bu hesabına bakın Peki çok kısa şey
dedim neleri yapmamamız lazım kesinlikle
Bunlar yapmamız gerekenler de de
esasında hissedenler vazgeçenler ben
yenildim diyenler Kaybedenler arkadaşlar
düşeceksiniz kalkacaksınız ama asla ve
asla Pes etmeyeceksin Ya bunu 1 numaralı
şey yazıp kesinlikle sorumluluktan
Kaçmayacak sınız sorumluluk aldığınız
zaman göreceksiniz Çok hızlı
farkedeceksiniz çok iyi işler
yapacaksınız yine meşhur hepinizin
bildiği nasa'daki temizlik işçisi e
hikayesi vardır Amerikan başkanı nasıl
dolaşırken orada bir işçiye rastlıyor
adam yerleri süpürüyordu ki senin burada
Görevin ne diyor işçi öyle güzel bir şey
söylüyor ki ben burada Nasılım uzaya
bir yollamazsa katkıda bulunuyorum diyor
yani bunun bahsettiğimiz temizlik
Dolayısıyla eşit Çünkü seveceksiniz
hayat durmaktan vazgeçmeyin sevmediğiniz
işte çalışmayın Bunlar altın kurallar
Yani ben diyorum güzel de para
kazanıyorum yaşlı işini değiştireyim
Ondan sonra demeyin her zaman 10.
yılında her yerde işlemleri duyuyorsunuz
15 yıla diyorsun 20 da duyuyorsunuz bir
Arkaya geçiyorum yoktur doğru zaman be
Allah senin işten bir önce kaçmaktır Ben
bölüp geçmiş yıllara baktığım zaman
Kendi kaderine görüyorum yaptığım
hatalar oldu hatasız hiç kimse olmaz
Hani öyle birisi varsa o doğruyu
söylemiyor dur Ama bir olarak mutluyum
Çünkü insanlara dokundum çok değerli
dostlarım çok değerli çalışma
arkadaşlarım oldu burada ekip
çalışmasının Değerini çok
Evet ee evet Tanrı çocuk kandırdım Seni
en büyük önem buydu yukarıya çok uzun
bir yol çok uzun bir maraton acele
etmeyin Bu maratonda bazen koşarken
geriye düşeceksiniz Bazen öyle
çıkacaksınız ama sonuç itibariyle
esasında bu yol sizin kendi olunuz yine
bak demiş yüreğinizdeki hissederseniz
mesafeler yoktur demiş Umarım siz de
kendi hayallerinizi kendi kariyeri
yüreğinde hisseder ve o yaylaya aldık
mesafesi bir önce alıyorsunuz Ee bugün
siz konuşması olduğu için balkonu sonuna
geldim Daha konuşacak çok şeyimiz var
Bana bir şey sormak isterseniz her zaman
bir hesaplama ulaşabilirsiniz bu
organizasyon ki çok teşekkür ediyorum
hayallerinizin peşinden koşuyorum Çok
teşekkürler